One announcement,
even though you will have no
academic exercises Thursday and
Friday, I know you would feel a
sense of shock,
disruption and dare I say
dislocation in your life if I did
not stick to schedule,
so there will be a skill testing
question on Tuesday based on
Homework 12. And that will be the
last one because the subsequent week
is the last week of semester.
And, since there is a final exam in
this subject, there can be no tests
during the last week of class,
so we will not have any weekly test.
Today I want to talk about
biochemistry. We are going to spend
the next three lectures on
biochemistry. This is the chemistry
of living organisms.
And I want to make several points
by way of introduction.
The first one is that living
organisms are chemical systems.
And they are governed by the same
laws that apply to inanimate matter.
We don't have a special chemistry.
And, in fact, I came across this
comment that was made by the Nobel
Laureate Richard Feynman who said
that if in some cataclysm all of
scientific knowledge were to be
destroyed and only one sentence
passed onto the next generations of
creatures, what statement would
contain the most information
in the fewest words?
"I believe that it is the atomic
hypothesis or the atomic fact or
whatever you wish to call it,
that all things are made of atoms.
Little particles that move around
in perpetual motion attracting each
other when they are a little
distance apart but repelling upon
being squeezed into one another.
The atomic hypothesis very
important. Second comment I want to
make is none of us is unaware of the
boom in biotechnology today.
What is the boom in biotechnology?
Why do we have the boom in
biotechnology?
It is really a boom in biochemical
technology. What is the modern
biology called?
It is called molecular biology.
And what is molecular science?
This is chemistry.
And, more importantly,
it is really not just chemical
composition but spatial arrangement.
Chemistry, materials science, solid
state chemistry underlies
the boom in biotech.
That is why we are going to spend
some time. We are spending 10% of
our lectures in 3.
91 on this topic. And,
last comment is, why only now?
Why didn't this happen 50 years ago?
What is enabling this boom today?
And the answer is complexity.
Let's get the answer out there.
The answer is complexity of the
chemistry.
And if you think about how materials
have evolved over time,
you know, we date our ages.
The ages of man are dated in terms
of materials. We have the Stone Age,
Bronze Age, Iron Age.
You might call the first half of
the 20th century the "Plastics Age."
You might call the last half of the
20th century the "Silicon Age."
And we see increasing complexity.
To work with stone, stone is found
in nature.
It requires only a change of shape.
But everything else, the metals,
the bronze, the iron are not found
in nature, native.
That requires a change in shape
after a change in chemical
composition. Chemistry is magic.
And chemists were revered as
sorcerers, magicians and were highly
respected. Not today.
There are compelling reasons to be
alive today, but not for the respect
given to chemists.
It is magic to take something and
convert its chemical composition.
And that took time to get the fires
hot enough to discover the chemistry
that would allow us to take a pile
of sand and turn it into a
semiconducting device so that you
could talk on a phone or type a
letter on a solid state device known
as a computer.
That took time.
Polymers come at the dawn of the
20th century.
Macromolecules.
It turns out that many of the
molecules in living organisms are
macromolecules,
so necessarily our understanding of
this chemistry had to wait for the
understanding of polymer chemistry.
Finally, now we have information
technology, we have our
understanding of macromolecules,
and now we can go forward with
biotechnology.
Let's get down to business and start
talking about the chemistry of
specific biomolecules.
And they fall broadly into four
categories. Let's document the four
categories of biomolecules.
We have, first of all, proteins.
Carbohydrates,
nucleic acids and lipids.
And, in the three lectures that we
have, I am going to focus primarily
on proteins, nucleic acids and
lipids. I think this will get you
far enough along to enjoy subsequent
chemistry. Let's get down to
business and start with proteins.
Protein comes from the Greek word
proteos which means of
first importance.
And these are macromolecules,
polymers of a sort. And they are
formed by polymerization.
And the mer groups that go into
this macromolecule are called amino
acids, formed by polymerization
of amino acids.
We better get a grip on what amino
acids are. As the name applies,
they must be compounds that have an
acid group. In other words,
capability of donating protons.
And amino means there must be some
kind of an NH formation.
Let's draw the skeletal structure
of a prototypical amino acid.
We start at the center with a
carbon that is sp3 hybridized.
And one of the terminals contains an
amino group which consists of this
formation bearing nitrogen.
The acid is given above. This is
carboxylic acid.
Carbon double bond to oxygen.
And then the OH. And this H is
capable of detaching. There
is the amino acid.
The third bond goes to oxygen.
Three of the four bonds are
uniquely specified in every amino
acid. Three of the four.
And now the fourth one, this is a
tetrahedron so I am trying to
indicate that this bond is receding
into the back,
is variable. And I am going to use
the carrier variable R.
And this is the term for the
substituent.
And this is nature's choice.
In principle, anything that will
covalently bond with a sigma bond
can be put here.
This means that there are thousands
and thousands of compounds that
qualify as amino acids,
but in proteins, only 20 found in
proteins. That is a short list.
It is a rather compact library.
Let's take a look at the types of
substituents. And for that you can
look at the table here in your
reading. This is from the table.
It actually spills over two pages.
I know that is very hard to read,
but it is more iconic just to sort
of symbolize that maybe somebody has
done the reading and they say I
recognize that table.
There are 20 different R groups,
20 different substituents. And they,
themselves, fall into four
categories. The R groups can be
broken down into four categories.
First one is nonpolar, the R group
is nonpolar. Clearly,
under that circumstance,
we would have something that is
hydrophobic. Nonpolar groups would
be less inclined to bond to water.
We have the option of polar groups.
Polar with hydrogen bonding
capability. And such groups are
going to be hydrophilic.
There is a third group that has a
net charge, so the R group is
actually net positive.
And so that means these are going
to be strongly hydrophilic.
They have a very high affinity for
water. And it turns out they will
function as basic in aqueous
solution. And then the last group
is a set of substituents that have a
net negative charge.
And this, too, are strongly
hydrophilic and will act acidic when
dissolved in water.
Now our bodies can synthesize only
ten of the twenty amino acids.
You will read in advertising that
certain foods contain some of the
essential amino acids,
meaning they contain some of the ten
amino acids that we are incapable of
processing. And failure to consume
this in the diet,
over a long period of time,
can have deleterious effects
prompting, in the extreme,
your exiting the carbon cycle.
You do want to watch your diet.
There is one other structural
feature that is important in the
amino acids, and that I want to show
with reference to a specific amino
acid. Let's choose alanine.
In alanine, the substituent group
is methyl CH3.
I can draw alanine as follows using
the skeletal structure to the left.
Here is the amino group which I am
just going to truncate as H2N.
And, maybe later, I am even going
to get so bold as to put NH2
recognizing that it is not the H
that is bridging to the nitrogen.
But let's do it this way. The
carboxylic acid will go up here,
will go here, and then we will just
put the methyl group.
Now, I could just as easily have
written it the following way.
I could have done this.
I could have put the amino group to
the right and the hydrogen to the
left. If you look at these two,
at first glance, you might say I
just have to turn it and he has
basically written the same thing.
But upon closer inspection you will
discover that it is impossible to
convert the one on the right to the
one on the left.
In fact, they are not
superimposable.
What we are looking at here is
essentially a pair of gloves.
This is considered the left hand and
this is the right hand.
And you can close the gloves.
You can make them fit one against
the other. They will mirror one
another across a mirror plane,
but they are not superimposable.
As opposed to something like, say,
propane. If I take propane, which
is also carbon sp3 hybridized,
in contrast it has methyl above and
below.
And that clearly is perfectly
symmetric and does not have such a
glove-like feature.
Such molecules that have,
we say, a handedness are called
chiral, from the Greek word for hand.
Chirality is the property of having
handedness, non-superimposable.
Another term for these is
stereoisomers.
We can consider chiral molecules
And the different hands,
if you will, are called enantiomers.
And we don't refer to one
stereoisomer or the other
stereoisomer. We refer to the
enantiomer coming from the Greek
word for mirror.
Enantios is the Greek word for
mirror. These are different
mirror images.
The other thing about these is that
they are optically active.
And what they will do is take
polarized light and rotate it
through a degree of polarization.
Just to give you another example of
the difference between something
that is chiral and not.
You see the boxes at the top with
no distinguishing features?
They can be twisted, turned and
made to superimpose over one another.
By putting these little features in
the bottom corner, we render
these boxes chiral.
And no matter how you twist and turn
this box, you won't be able to
superimpose it on top of the other
box. Here is a more complicated
molecule that can come chemically
identical but has a right-handed
version and a left-handed version.
Let's talk about optical activity.
The only reason I refer to this is
that it gives the labels that are
used in referring to one
versus the other.
If you have a light source that just
gives light that is randomly
polarized, that is to say it is not
polarized, and then you put it
through a polarizing prism so that
the light is polarized in a certain
direction. In other words,
the electric vector is only in one
direction. Now the polarized light,
here it is indicating that it is
polarized vertically.
This is the optically active
substance which could include an
aqueous solution of alanine.
And, if the aqueous solution of
alanine consists of only one
enantiomer, then when the polarized
light passes through that solution,
the plane of polarization will be
rotated a certain amount by
interaction of the light with the
electrons in the orbitals in this
particular molecule.
And what you see here is an angle
of rotation alpha where alpha is
proportional to the concentration of
the chiral species.
And also the path length through the
solution. If we put in both
enantiomers, we expect no change.
If we put in one enantiomer, we
will have one direction.
And so it turns out that the
different enantiomers will cause
different directions of rotation.
And this is how they are labeled.
The one that I have shown here on
the right will cause a clockwise
rotation of the light.
And so it is termed D as in
dextrorotatory from the Latin word
for right. This is the
dextrorotatory form.
And then the one here on the left
will cause the light - And I am
going to write h nu here.
It is the plane of polarization of
the light that is rotating.
The plane of polarization, if it
went through a solution that
consisted of only the enantiomer
depicted on the left,
would move in the left direction.
And, even though the Latin word for
left is sinister,
they didn't call it sinistrorotatory.
They call it levorotatory.
I guess they had to go the Slavic
languages to get a root word.
Levorotatory is this one. Some
will call this the positive
enantiomer and the left one the
negative enantiomer,
but in most of the reading that you
will encounter it will
be the D and the L.
It turns out that only the L form of
amino acids are found in proteins.
Only L enantiomer of amino acids
are found in proteins.
But synthesis could give rise to
both. And certainly chemical
synthesis will give rise to both.
I am not going to spend much time
on carbohydrates,
but just for reference,
the carbohydrates are also chiral
molecules. It turns out that in
sugars only D form is metabolized
by our bodies.
You may have heard of invert sugar
or baker's sugar.
This is simply the L form of the
various sugars.
And this passes unrecognized
through the body.
Honey contains the L form of the
carbohydrate because it is processed
by bees, and the bees have a
different biological apparatus.
There is science fiction where
somebody is after some grand event.
Finds themselves at a strange place.
It always has to be a desert island.
And they end up eating fruit that
happens to be chock full of energy,
but it is the wrong enantiomer. And
the people, although they are filled
to satiety, die because they cannot
process the food.
That is the basis.
That plot line has been used
already, I am sorry to tell you,
so you cannot use it now.
And, when both enantiomers are
present, this is called racemic.
And this is very important, as I
said it is a matter of life and
death, in pharmaceuticals.
I will tell you one example.
Back in the 1960s there was a drug
that was produced by a German
pharmaceutical company
called thalidomide.
Thalidomide was developed as an
anticonvulsant and it was also good
as a sedative for people that were
severely depressed.
One of the properties of
thalidomide was that you could not
overdose on it.
If a person took a huge quantity of
thalidomide, it would make the
person comatose,
you would go into a deep sleep,
you would be an extra on the set of
Rip Van Winkle, but you could
not kill yourself.
An unintended benefit of thalidomide
was discovered by pregnant women in
Europe who learned that consumption
of thalidomide had a tremendous
palliate effect on morning sickness,
particularly early in the pregnancy,
so people started using it for a
palliative against morning sickness.
This was only in Europe. The Food
and Drug Administration in the
United States said it has not been
subjected to enough testing and
refused to allow its importation
into the United States.
And there was a lot of clamoring
saying the FDA is old-fashioned,
they are in the pockets of the drug
companies, they are holding up the
advance of drugs and so on.
And you hear these charges with
respect to cancer drugs and drugs in
the treatment of AIDS where people
are inpatient for solutions.
The FDA held its ground, but much
of the drug did find its way into
the United States.
And then shortly after its
widespread consumption,
it was found that this is a
teratogen and produces
hideous birth defects.
And people said,
what went wrong? Why did they not
discover this?
Was it not tested?
Was it not tested on animal models?
And the answer is it was tested on
animal models.
It turns out that all the animal
models that it was tested on,
those animals lacked a particular
enzyme that processes thalidomide
the way it is processed in humans.
This is something that caused quite
a stir at the time.
But what is the punch line?
The punch line is it is a chiral
molecule.
Only one enantiomer causes the birth
defects, but nobody knew at the time.
If they had known,
and instead of selling a racemic
form and sold a form that has only
the one enantiomer,
they could have had the beneficial
effects without the undesirable
effects. And now thalidomide is
back in the news.
Some people have discovered that it
may have some benefit as a component
of a cocktail that is being used in
the treatment of AIDS. But
the memory lingers on.
By the way, Ritalin,
which is used in the treatment of
ADHD, is also chiral.
And it has been produced without
regard to its chirality.
It is now emerging that the D
enantiomer, the D form is effective
in the treatment of ADHD.
And the L form is ineffective.
And some of the undesirable side
effects of long-term use of Ritalin
may, in fact, be linked to the L
enantiomer. What you are seeing
more and more in drug design is
attention paid to the structure.
It is the structure. In fact, why
don't I cut to the chase.
This is what drug design is all
about in like two minutes.
Let's say this is some receptor
molecule and it has little dipoles
here. This is a delta minus and
this is a delta plus.
And maybe this is a delta minus and
this is a delta plus just
arbitrarily. And this is some
candidate drug that is supposed to
come up to this receptor.
And the drug is designed to react.
What is going on is really a lock
and key mechanism.
And you know the Debye frequency.
It is about ten trillion hertz.
Ten trillion times a second nature
puts the system to the test.
On one of those tests, suppose this
drug that is supposed to bind to
this receptor where this is delta
minus, this is delta plus,
where this is delta plus, this is
delta minus and so on,
the two will stay together long
enough to do the math and figure out
that there is some more energy to be
gained through a further
chemical reaction.
If, on the other hand,
this is somehow misformed so that
opposite this delta minus is also a
delta minus, during that collision
there won't be that staying power to
keep things together long enough.
And so the activation will not be
achieved. And so the reaction won't
go forth. Really,
the message here is that atomic
arrangement is the key.
With a pun here,
it's the key. This is a lock and
key mechanism,
and atomic arrangement is the key,
paying attention to chirality. Of
course, the other thing is let's
understand the chemistry to such a
high degree that we are not relying
on field testing to sort of
determine whether something is
acceptable or not.
We need to get rid of empiricism
and ramp up the determinism.
Let's talk about properties of amino
acids. What are the properties of
these compounds?
Well, first of all,
they are solids at room temperature.
And they can crystallize.
They can be crystalline. Remember,
these are the mer groups. They are
not the polymers.
These are the mer groups that have
yet to be polymerized.
They can crystallize. I think it
is fair to say they are going to be
colorless, entirely covalent,
highly bonded. And they are
moderately soluble in water,
which is a good thing for something
that is going to function as a
biomolecule. I think solubility in
water is desirable.
In fact, I want to look a little
more closely at the
behavior in water.
And to mention that the first thing
that happens, this thing transforms.
And in the chart that is in the
book, that Bio Table 1,
you do not see the amino acids drawn
as I have drawn them with the amino
end neutral and the carboxylic end
neutral. They draw them as follows.
They show what happens when the
amino acid has already been
dissolved in water.
Let's represent that solvation
reaction. I am going to compact the
notation. Here is the central
carbon, there is the hydrogen,
there is the amino substituent on
the bottom, and on the top I am
going to put the carboxylic acid.
Let's ask what happens when this
dissolves in water at neutral pH.
This does not necessarily mean pH
equals 7. It means neutral with
respect to this reaction
we are going to show.
What happens when this species
dissolves in water is the proton
leaves the carboxylic acid and comes
over and attaches to the amino end.
Look at the amino end. This is
really a Bronsted base.
This is an Arrhenius acid.
It is also a Bronsted acid.
Now we have, from what is a neutral
molecule, something that looks like
this, protons attached here
rendering this end positive.
The R group remains unchanged.
And the carboxylic acid is now
minus the proton.
This molecule is still net neutral
because I have charge neutrality to
maintain. All I have done is
relocate something within the
molecule, but it is bipolar.
That is to say it is locally
positive and locally negative,
but globally it is net neutral.
It is kind of a strange ion.
Is it an ion or is it not an ion?
It is net neutral so we wouldn't
call it an ion.
Instead of an ion,
it is called a zwitterion,
which means a double ion.
Zwitterion or a double ion,
some kind of a hybrid.
That is really important chemistry
because that gives this molecule the
ability to respond to its
environment. Somehow,
through the chemistry, we have to
explain how matter becomes animate.
What is the chemistry here? I mean,
how do I do this?
How do I move my hand?
This is all macromolecular,
so what am I doing when I move my
hand? I am changing the
confirmation of those polymers.
Those polymers are changing shape.
Remember the C17H36? I showed you
two long chains.
One was relatively straight and one
was coiled. And I can go from one
confirmation to the other.
How do I do that? The electrical
engineers are going to say it is all
electrical. I say,
no, it is not electrical.
You cannot do this electrically.
Where are the wires? This is
chemical. It is all chemical,
and I am going to show you how.
But you say you cannot do it that
fast.
Fast is fast only in the mind of the
beholder. This simply has to happen
at a rate that is keeping pace with
the conversation.
On a geological timescale this is a
vanishingly short period of time.
Otherwise, as long as our data rate
of understanding can keep pace with
the ability for us to change the
confirmation, we live.
Let's look at how this responds.
Suppose this is, I don't know, in
the wall of the stomach.
And you get a hankering for some
cola beverage and you drink the cola.
The cola is low pH.
It is about pH 3, phosphoric acid,
benzoic acid. What is going to
happen is this Zwitterion will
respond in a defensive manner.
There is a principle in chemistry
that is analogous to a Newton's
Third Law, action-reaction.
It is called the Le Chatelier
Principle after the French scientist
who enunciated it.
The Le Chatelier Principle talks
about the restorative force exerted
by a chemical system.
And what is this restorative force
designed to do?
It is designed to minimize the
impact of any perturbation.
By perturbation,
I mean not a physical perturbation,
I mean a chemical shift, any kind of
chemical perturbation.
Let's say we have the zwitterion
sitting happily in a neutral
solution and suddenly the pH drops.
How can the zwitterion respond?
What do I do to bring the pH back
to where it was before to the
disturbance? What is the
manifestation of pH?
It is proton. Somehow the proton
concentration suddenly went way up
driving the pH way down.
And I am zwitterion sitting here.
Here is zwitterion right here.
What could zwitterion do to minimize
the impact of this flood of proton?
Well, there are two possibilities.
How do you neutralize something?
You either start flooding this with
hydroxyl in order to neutralize.
I look on zwitterion and see no
hydroxyl, so that is no good.
But what could zwitterion do?
At the carboxylic acid end there is
an attachment site for proton.
What zwitterion can do is to gobble
up the excess proton in order to
bring the pH back to
where it was before.
Let's write that reaction.
It triggers this response.
There is the amino end.
I am going to put the carboxylic
acid over to the right here.
Now this is from the solution.
It is trying to bring the pH back
to where it was before consuming the
proton and attaching the proton to
this carboxylic acid end.
What has happened now to zwitterion?
The negative end has been capped.
Zwitterion now is net positive.
Over here it is net neutral.
And it is gobbling up protons from
the solution. And so this is really
an acid-base reaction for which I
can write a k,
an acid dissociation constant.
And I am getting tired writing all
these characters so I am going to
reformat this.
I am going to represent the
zwitterion as proton plus the rest.
This is proton.
And what is this thing here?
This is now zwitterion to which
proton has attached.
I have attached this proton to the
net neutral species.
I can rewrite this reaction in a
more compact notation.
A captures all of this other stuff
minus the proton.
I can write the K for that reaction.
K1 will equal the concentration of
proton times the concentration of
neutral zwitterion over the
concentration of this protonated
zwitterion, **K1 = [H+][HA]/[HAH]**
the zwitterion onto which we have
glommed this proton
from the solution.
And we are going to take a page out
of Sorensen's book.
And we will take the log of both
sides. And then we can say that pK1
is equal to pH plus log.
And I am writing 10 here,
but in engineering, if you see log
it is typically log base 10.
I know in some of the math classes
they use the log to represent
natural log, but it is uncommon in
engineering. Here is the "Sorensen
version" of the equation.
What this tells us is that at 50%
association --
In other words,
when 50% of the zwitterion has
gobbled up the proton to generate
this protonated species,
this ratio is equal, 50% zwitterion
unprotonated, 50% protonated.
So the log of one is zero. And
that is the pH that gives us the
value of the acid dissociation
constant. At 50% of consumption of
zwitterion, we have the
concentration of zwitterion equaling
the concentration of the
protonated zwitterion.
And, therefore,
the pH is exactly at the value of
pK1. Now, what happens on the other
extreme? What happens if all of a
sudden there is a rise in pH?
If there is a sudden rise in pH,
how does zwitterion respond?
That means the concentration of
proton suddenly fell,
so we use the Le Chatelier Principle
again. We use the Le Chatelier
Principle. We go back over here and
look at zwitterion.
We say what we have right now is a
sudden dearth of,
a shortage of proton.
How can zwitterion respond to that
sudden shortage of proton?
Well, the neutral zwitterion has
protons sitting right here.
What zwitterion can do,
in response to that sudden drop in
proton concentration,
is donate, become a proton donor and
start adding protons to the solution,
sacrificing its neutrality in order
to minimize the impact of that
sudden rise in pH.
Let's document that reaction.
That is this one here. That is
where zwitterion does the following.
We will start with the neutral
again.
That is over here.
H3N. Here is the neutral
zwitterion. It experiences a sudden
rise in pH and responds by dumping
protons into the solution.
Now the left end is deprotonated
leaving it neutral.
And this proton is now donated to
the solution. And if this solution
is, in fact, high in pH then this
proton can go and attack the excess
hydroxyl and neutralize it.
This is how zwitterion responds.
And what do we see here? This is
net neutral. But now the positive
end has become neutralized by the
loss of the proton so this
is now net negative.
And so we can call this reaction two,
and it has a K2.
And, using the notation that I have
developed up there,
the neutral zwitterion I am denoting
HA. This is the zwitterion minus
this proton, so this is just the A
minus. It is making sense.
This is net negative. And,
if I take H away from HA, I get
minus. And then this is the H plus.
That is the reaction we are looking
at. And we can write the k for that
reaction as concentration of proton
times concentration of deprotonated
zwitterion divided by the
concentration of the neutral
zwitterion. **K2 = [H+][A-]/[HA]**
And take the log base 10 of both
sides, pK2 is pH plus log base 10
I am going to flip this over so that
I don't have to put a minus sign
here. This would be HA divided by A
minus. Again,
when we have 50% neutralization then
that means there will be 50% of this
species consumed,
50% of this left, the log of one is
zero. And at that pH we have the
value of the acid dissociation
constant.
And I think this slide shows what is
going on here.
All it does is plots these two
equations. If you take the first
equation here,
the logarithmic,
the Sorensen form of the first
equation, that is the lower part of
this graph. We are plotting pH
versus the ion dissociation.
If you turn this around, pH versus
the amount of this that
has been consumed.
And what you see is that when you
have 50%, this is 50% ions
dissociated per molecule,
you have pK1 where both are equal.
The other thing to note is that, as
this reaction is taking place,
look at the gentle change in pH,
the concentration here changes from
roughly about 10% up to 90%.
We have an 80% variation in
concentration.
And by that I mean an 80% interval
over which we are changing the
amount of attachment here.
Here there is no attachment.
Here there is total attachment.
And in the middle we have, from
about 10% to 90% attachment,
the pH only moves about two units.
Zwitterion is fighting really,
really hard to get this pH up to a
certain level and hold it there.
We say that the zwitterion,
under these circumstances, is acting
as a buffer. Zwitterion acts as a
buffer. What it will do,
it has the capacity to either donate
protons or remove protons,
and do so in a way that reduces the
impact of the pH.
And then here is the other part of
the graph, the upper part,
the case where we have a sudden rise
in pH.
The pH goes up and zwitterion is now
holding the pH as best it can around
a value of pK2.
There is a special point on this
graph shown right here where we have
maximum undissociated zwitterion.
In other words, what is the pH at
which we have 100% undissociated
zwitterion, just the zwitterion.
And that is given by the balance
between the K1 and the K2.
That is called the isoelectric
point, because then everything is
net neutral. And that is also given
the notation pI,
lowercase p, capital I for
isoelectric.
And, in this case,
it's simply the average of pK1 and
pK2. And this can be found for
various amino acids.
I don't expect you to know the
amino acid compositions by heart.
I would always give you the
chemical formula of the amino acid.
And, if you had to do anything with
such calculations,
I would tell you what the K1 or the
K2 is as the case may be.
There is one other twist on this.
There are a few amino acids where
the R groups are also capable of
attaching or donating protons.
We say that the R groups are
titratable. That is to say they can
also be proton active and can
participate in this Le Chatelier
Principle in action.
And, if you look on the homework,
Question 11 goes through an analysis
of how you deal with a situation
where there is a change in pH.
And, for example, suppose you have
a side group. Aspartic acid is a
good example. In aspartic acid the
R group is methylene.
And then there is a carboxylic acid
sticking off. This is the R group.
Clearly, this is a site of
attachment. If I get a sudden drop
in pH, there is a flood of hydrogen
ions. The hydrogen ions can be
attaching not only to the carboxylic
acid end here,
but they can also be attaching on
the R group. That brings a new
level of complexity,
and we work that out in the
particular homework example.
Let's take a break here now,
and I will leave you with five
minutes on extreme kinetics.
Earlier in the semester, I went up
to Halifax to give a seminar and was
reminded of this.
Actually, our audiovisual
technician, Dave Broderick,
had brought to my attention a number
of years ago. We talked about the
extremes in kinetics, one
of them being explosion.
The reason I tell you about this,
it follows kinetics, and also it is
apropos of the season.
After Thanksgiving Day when you go
downtown, you will see a feature
that I am going to tell you about at
the end of this story.
On December 6, 1917, this was in
the middle of World War I and Canada
was part of the British Empire at
the time and was drawn into the war,
Halifax was a port of exchange of a
lot of munitions.
There was the Belgian relief ship,
the Imo, and the French supply ship,
the Mont Blanc. This is the cargo
of the Mont Blanc.
And you can see it was a potent
cargo, to be sure.
At 8:45 AM there was a collision.
The Imo hit the Mont Blanc. It
missed the TNT,
there was 20,000 tons of it,
but it struck the picric acid,
which was stored directly beneath
the drums of benzol,
and there were some sparks.
And so, that is the way the story
begins.
And for this one,
in this light, I think I will put on
some glasses so that I can read it
to you in modern English.
The crew of the Mont Blanc,
aware of their cargo, immediately
took to the lifeboats screaming
warnings that no one heeded.
They rode for Dartmouth, which is
across the harbor.
The Mont Blanc drifted by Halifax
Pier brushing it and setting it
ablaze. Members of the Halifax Fire
Department responded quickly and
were positioning their engine up to
the nearest hydrant when the Mont
Blanc disintegrated in a blinding
white flash creating the biggest
man-made explosion before
the Nuclear Age.
It was 9:05 AM.
Over 1,900 people were killed
immediately. Within a year,
the figure had climbed to well over
2,000, 9,000 more injured,
many permanently, 325 acres,
almost all of North End Halifax
destroyed, and much of what was not
immediately leveled burned to the
ground, added by winter stockpiles
of coal in cellars.
As for the Mont Blanc,
all 3,000 tons of her were shattered
into little pieces that were
blasted far and wide.
The barrel of one of her cannons
landed 3.5 miles away,
part of her anchor shank weighing
over half a ton flew 2 miles in the
opposite direction,
windows shattered 50 miles away and
the shockwave was felt even in
Sydney, Cape Breton 270 miles
northeast. There was about 20
minutes between the collision and
the explosion,
enough time for spectators,
including many children, to run to
the waterfront to watch the ship
burning, thus, coming
into close range.
It was enough time for others to
gather at windows and,
thus, an exceptionally large number
of people were injured by flying
glass. Many sustained permanent eye
damage. Not surprisingly,
hospitals were unable to cope with
so many wounded.
Also the misery was compounded by a
blizzard that struck the city the
following day dumping 16 inches of
snow over the ruins of their sooty,
oily covering. With astounding
speed, relief efforts were set into
motion, money poured in from as far
away as China and New Zealand.
The Canadian government gave - so
much money. But most Haligonians,
which is what you call a resident of
Halifax, remember the generosity of
the State of Massachusetts which
donated $750,000 in money and goods
and gave unstintingly and volunteer
assistance to The Massachusetts
Halifax Relief Committee.
People from the hospitals,
Mass Eye and Ear, went up because so
many people had sustained eye damage.
They got on trains and went up
there to minister to these people.
To this day, Halifax sends an annual
Christmas tree to The City of Boston
in gratitude. When you go downtown,
I don't know where it is now, it
used to be in front of the
Prudential, but I heard recently
they relocated it to the Boston
Common, if you see a 45 foot
Christmas tree that looks like it
came from Canada,
that is the reason.
Have a happy Thanksgiving.
I will see you next week.